messieurs dames bonjour bonjour le
concept d'aujourd'hui je laime
particulièrement vous savez on est tous
fans ici des sosies ça nous fait mourir
noël j'ai déjà fait des bisous à ce
sujet il ya pas mal de temps cette ville
a carrément un conte un stade presque
celle sur laquelle il pose des photos de
ses sosies on est très fan de ça
aujourd'hui on a trouvé une idée de
concept qui peut potentiellement
complètement foiré mais qui n'en sera
pas pour le moins moins amusante
l'audace nous allons faire venir s'y
abonner à tour de rôle chacun pense
qu'il vient pour faire une activité
manuelle avec nous à savoir de la
poterie ce que sympa déjà comme ça va
faire de la poterie marisa vendredi on
aurait
pu nous avons un objectif secret
aujourd'hui il y a trois sosies un sosie
de scène un sosie de lorraine un sosie
de moi j'ai une question comment vous
avez fait le casting raté leur insu ciel
développé par la sq within distribue
très fort nous allons devoir pendant
cette fausse vidéo activités manuelles
nous remplacer chacun deux tours par
notre source c'est à dire va devoir
chacun deux tours se lever sortir la
pièce et faire rentrer notre soutien à
notre place évidemment la bonne et va
s'en rendre compte au bout d'un moment
donc le vrai but c'est pas qu'il se rend
pas compte c'est qu'ils n'osent pas le
dire à haute voix sachant que quand vous
envoyez votre sosie vous allez en
cuisine et tu vois là et tu as un retour
vidéo de ce qui se passe ici donc tu
peux voir un peu comment ça se passe
pour les collègues moi je veux qu
aujourd'hui sur ces six personnes l'une
d'entre elle se retrouve assise ici avec
nos trois sosies sans avoir osé dire
quoi que ce soit attendez je vous
préviens ces crimes gens ça va vous
glace expliqué
m il est donc maintenant le temps de
rencontrer nos ssii qui pour le moment
sont pas des sosies sont plus des gens
qui nous ressemblent plus ou moins et on
va devoir du coup à billets comme nous
grimé comme nous coiffer comme nous pour
qu'on se ressemble le plus plus plus
possible chacun rejoint son sosie et on
se retrouve après on découvre les choses
et les autres allez allez on va
comment s'appelle passer jusqu'à y toi
c'est le cas aussi en croire dit
s'appelle lucas le casting est
complètement réussi tu es lisse et
lucylle mucy lucio on n'est pas loin mes
grands mères metellus téléfiction
j'aie jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui
vous ressemble c'est la preuve est donc
juste pour ça je suis très honorée que
sur toi union dalle premier sosie ben
moubamba vous en gros nous c'est le plus
risqué les abonnés qui vont venir tir
regarde mes vidéos ils m'ont scanner
m'ont vu mille fois à l'écran donc ils
savent parfaitement à quoi je ressemble
nous on a un peu cet avantage là ceux
qui vont plus est sur lucas sur seb ils
ont plus l'habitude de les voir et c'est
son habitude de me voir mais pas tant
que ça je fais des vidéos sur la musique
si jamais ils sont là ils disent ouais
lourd tesson d'un alain tu dis y'a du
lourd qui arrive c'est comme être sur le
dos ce qui se passe en bas atteints
d'affections wii voir nos fringues on a
les mêmes chaussures on a les mêmes
chaussettes t-shirt super jogging si tu
renverses un truc là dessus on est mort
hilton tout à toi je pensais pas mais
c'est génial teint pitié par contre que
ça marche bien du chômage bon
d'accord c'est la tonne de quand je les
fais c'est ça ouais
nous allons désormais découvrir les
sosies quasi parfait
je voudrais juste une astuce plus lors
enrique ans le mien mois il laisse aussi
des conditions parfaites pour garder la
foi c'est twilight vous allez voir est
ce qu'on peut faire entrer le loup sud
[Musique]
ouf rien des scans bouleversant c'est
marrant première à chaque fois c'est bah
oui je regarde ça nous on a un pronostic
c'est qu'on ne fait pas griller une
seule fois deux peines aix est confiée
au regard des biens d'autrui pendant que
les filles pour être ensemble parce que
vous êtes trouver les stations
fm tellement envie de partager ok comme
ça fait sérieux gwendal vas-y vas-y je
te laisse applique van damme gwendal
bienvenus
c'est drôle ça arrive à moi je suis pas
efficace ah ouais ouais ouais on va
passer un merveilleux moment moi sachez
que mon souci elle mène présentement il
s'appelle lucas on accueille le pire du
coup aller lucas 2
malgré ces quoi j'ai envie de laisser
les deux faire une vidéo
inspirée déjà enchanté tout le monde on
chantait tout le monde fasse a fait
voler monde on regarde le détail la
franchise mon fiancé personne ne s'est
pas vous pousser à bout d'essai avalisé
jeudi un truc lâché en fout stress
vraiment je gère très mal les situations
qui ns là et là on va vis du christ mon
pote du judo kling voir le but de cette
croissance coutu complet est ce que vous
êtes très étrange de penser non
clairement non mais vous allez gaullisme
c'est pratique pour
chanter désolé pour la tente là tu as vu
il ya plein de caméras c'était long
d'installer tout en plus est la première
à passer un g freche la pression moi je
suis excité à dire si
nous sommes avec asma la fin personne
avec qui on va faire de la sculpture
désolé ça commence un peu direct
je rappelle asma 20 minutes pour faire
l'objet sur lequel on va tomber j'ai
hâte de faire son charme voilà je dis si
on a vu
et ben les amis le but c'est d'avoir la
plus belle banane à la 29 minute et 19
secondes non mais ça va franchement 30
minutes pour une banale l'ol a déjà fini
regarder les gars
est quoi ce bordel dans moi j'aimerais
vous aussi vous pouvez faire pisser
[ __ ] est-ce que
vous avez jusqu'à 6 h 15 4 si on m'a dit
vas-y van gogh paltrow non lorraine va
aux toilettes sans qu'au préalable avant
voilà c'est pour ça parce que je me dis
moi j'ai un peu le torturer si j'aurai
moi mon truc
monstrueux qui l'est plus c'est hyper du
swing
[Musique]
en fait ces choix d'avoir une forme
nickel tout ça va tu t'en sors mais
encore mais je me vois l'image c'est
l'impression d'être dans matrix entraîne
pas du retard il faut que tu bambins
pourront-ils on va let's go let go
voyages pas subi
vas-y
tu vois
[Rires]
attend elle lance des regards alors
voilà d'ingres et
à la banane est devenue une pirogue et
transforme tout en pirogue les deux mais
c'est bien parce qu'elle est bien
concentré à les hyper concentré le
silence mais regarde comment on est mort
on dirait qu'on est en fait la gueule en
eau lourde chute en sorte de fou là
c'est un truc de fou sans déconner on
est à venise ou quoi
non comment c'est possible c'est kolo de
compliquer encore
on est partout là je peux me laver les
mains à valenciennes
j'en ai partout
or
dès la première manche non c'est
franchement c'est
[Musique]
tu es content parce que ta
bouche de il faut qu'ils parlent
[Musique]
à
l'assouplissement
des mecs font pas trop avant
tu paies lampaul
[Musique]
le voir tourner où je disais si
le talent mode c'est ok
je me tiens et de leighton
j'ai passé après je me suis dit mais
bien la bouche des sables à
asma on t'apprend qu est ce parce que le
vrai but de la vidéo c'est pas la banane
c'est juste à quel moment tu t'es dit
attends il ya un blème c'est juste quand
j'ai vu à wes jusqu'à jusqu'à lucas oil
une note sur 10 de notre prestation
sociale on s'était dit
je tiens quand même à ce qu'on note les
bananes ska miles a tout donné je
n'oserais elle est très bien merci nous
sépare
c'est mon rôle est assumée s'assure de
l'eau saint denis souhait d'asmar
maintenant au montage
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut applaudir as mind and
africa et à
la classe ouvrière s'appelle a primé
fumigènes c'était ouvre mais on a
atteint l'objectif là dès la première
mois mais après j'ai énormément parlé et
le souci c'est que les gars a briefé
bosnie voici l'endroit qui veut répondre
au
travers des vous nous entends plus
là en face au level 2 les sosies paris
avec
bilal et frappe un peu un truc manuel
villar way up lanouf d'avant on nous a
juste mis la misère wade a nous a tués
mathieu je te rassure je suis nul nous
recevons avec nous bilal oui
c'est moi même c'est le moment de faire
tes preuves et on va avoir un modèle qui
va nous étonner nous avons dix minutes
c'est 10 minutes ok waouh ok un escargot
est ok ok c'est trop mignon à l'escargot
en plus c'est pas si mignon je crois je
crois que tu te trompes permettent si je
puis me permettre on a un truc pour
sculpter on vous prend des couteaux à la
nuit tu attends je vais le retrait de la
texture et où l'on soit une oeuvre d'art
non coûteuse il valide et attendez je
n'aurais sujet serait comme son chef
robert de temps
je sais pas si je pourrais commenter le
j'en sais pas ce que je fais
tout
semble aller comme chacun sait le voile
intégral quand justin ans en lorraine
saveurs
septembre à bien
ok ok
brenda nous déconseille genre c'est toi
la bosse en fait je suis concentré
qui nous sort l'escargot sundin qui joue
sa minute attends je vais me sécher les
mains parce que j'ai trop de trucs je me
sens chez moi je vais faire la technique
de bilal direct
[Musique]
you
[Rires]
may dommage collatéral moi j'aime pas à
dieu
j'ai connu gary l'escargot dow est moche
oui je pense que je parle bien sûr ils
peuvent
fait qu'il ya un problème d'âge et
encore on retombait
donc en fait
le pâté
j'avais du coup
je déconne
[Musique]
alors moi j'en étais aux antennes la
double switch sait pas tout ce qui est
même pas
[Musique]
la force
là franchement on est serré il n'ya pas
y'a pas quelqu'un qui se démarque des
autres
est ce que quelqu'un veut souligner
quelque chose ou est ce que je rentre
chez moi et je laisse le calcul la
journée ici tu finis par tous je me fais
tuer on en a mais je vous rappelle qu'on
parte assure des tabliers et je vais en
gagner bilans je vais les engueuler
bilan précis bilal mon frère
je me dis il est sorti et
l'insaisissable sens et vince aussitôt
au g20 solution c'est incroyable c'est
un trajet mais après
il a gagné
et une nouvelle fois c'est l'abonné qui
gagnent de très très long avec la
sculpture mellal mon frère tu margaret
rhodes et les amis déjà pourquoi ça se
passe aussi bien c'est trop suspect en
fait on a sous-estimé à quel point c'est
impressionnant de devoir dire c'était
pas toi là il ya deux minutes c'est
hyper dur je ne veux plus rester ici
jusqu'à la fin je n'en peux plus reste
que moi qui reste ici jusqu'à la fin ok
ok moi ce que je propose déjà s'est
construite l'idéal serait que c'est moi
qui partent en premier la personne la
plus proche
voila voila je vais faire très discrète
moi je vais me donner à fond mon sosie
le truc c'est que lui on peut lui
demander de beaucoup parler bah moi je
vais le lancer alors il mais elle arrive
en disant hey you
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi ton prénom ellison ellison et
lycéens venus ici se développe ici ouais
t'as déjà fait de la poterie mme pas du
goût jamais rien tu as fait que tu as
fait tout manuel genre descend du pénis
en arts plastiques
comptait garder ce détail valentine nous
sommes très tous prêts
pouvant mais couronne prétend que c'est
super dur s'est dit ça et dégage une
astuce c'est un bol et ont fait un trou
dedans
mais en vrai ce qui est dur c'est la
poterie et attend de toi tu es licence
d'arts plastiques l'as des tatamis en
fait je vais est surveillante je vais
passer un concours trois ans après pour
devenir prof d'arts plastiques et à si
je peux faire à côté essayer de faire du
stream qui doit jouer à quoi et ans on
joue beaucoup à leur compagne moi je
peux aller chercher un couteau pour lui
a carrément en plus j'allais dire à
mazda la ramenant de toi t'as vu une opé
twitch sur leur compagnie toile est si
gentille à capter je le sens ici les
jeux il aa merci saturé galles tiens on
a des coups tous très bien je laissais
un espèce de chantier tous habitude vais
te mettre une note sur 10 en activité
manuelle qu'il donnerait combien pour
l'instant moins en moins n'a a pas c'est
pas moi ont fait ce choix je les plains
as tu veux que j'aille le hockey n'ont
même pas et c'est bien pourquoi 10
secondes vas-y vas-y continuez continuez
continuez je pense patrick
ça peut marcher on voit le son truc on
le détruit vite fait bien fait ça c'est
pas notre problème
non mais il ya eu un travail artistique
j'allais le dire oui j'allais lui dire
regarde ça va 0,6 et rec rec c'est hyper
et sa part loin là et je suis plutôt
fier de ce que je fais
j'aurais pu dire ça voilà bah oui mais
s'ils
savent on est toujours dans le monde
dans l'absurde conceptuel en vrai c'est
vachement beau but le rennais lead tu
manges pour toi ta spécialité c'était le
bon bah c'est légal de trois minutes
j'étais en train de faire la grimace
[Musique]
quand j'étais au collège j'avais un prof
d'arts plastiques qui nous tes à la tête
c'est vrai ouais mais bon ça c'est leur
boulot mais il faut
compter les frais la santé du coup
comment
la chance bah oui parce que on va dire
que
c'était très bien prenez beaucoup mieux
que la nôtre à ce compte en 2030
et comment vous faites moi j'exerce en
mariant
avec toutes les activités manuelles
qu'on a fait en plus qu on laisse le
compteur
attends rien de technique on a une
technique et si on la laisse comprendre
non
civiles et moi t'as rien dit mais parce
que je me suis dit que c'était normal de
notre coeur jours à faire du coût
au cas où il ya quelques jours on a des
copies de nous disponibles en
vidéo à griller à quel moment qu'il y
avait un truc qui cloche et qui avaient
fui les partis et les gars j'ai fait
c'est bizarre mais vraiment je ne savais
pas que c'était bien car
c'est fou que sur trois personnes y en
ait aucune qui dit un truc il va falloir
faire une dinguerie va devoir augmenter
le niveau messieurs dames on en a marre
là que ça se passe trop bien là on va on
va y aller au culot de fou première
étape lorraine à une brillante idée us
il est caché dès le début sous la table
et moi je préfère c'est que je vais
prendre un outil de lolo et je vais
l'envoyer sous la table et en envoyant
sur la table du coup je veux dire à
havas chercher arabe horrible blague
mais le swap en trouve deux il va être
chaud parce que celui-ci la sorte par là
bas pendant que toi tu rentres et non
pas d'en faire tu
vois si je vais creed j'ai raté trop
chiant et tout grâce du prion mes frères
nous sommes au level 4 le 24
et
là la bouche trou de la salopette la
baule ce héros
découvre tu vas découvrir la rive dans
l'atelier comment tu t'appelles chris
willis
willis était prêt je lance ce chrono
d'une minute dès que valentine nous a
montré l'objet à copier attention il
s'agit des lunettes
avec des lunettes hockey lazio il faut
faire des branches donc prenez le
couteau pour découper votre truc
explique on devient professionnel a
maintenant j'ai alors regardé je vais
faire un truc hein le l'oise avoir
besoin de scouts au hockey oui ok l'ol
est très forte par rapport à nous mais
elle va aller chercher le couteau [ __ ]
c'est comme ça au manga du temps mais
tu le trouves le look tout va bien qu'il
trouve ton couteau
allez bonne chance on qu'il se cherche
et on kiffe sachets non mais ok d'accord
c'est comme celà va bien
ok tu me lis je peux faire tout en même
temps c'est à dire que moi je préfère la
poterie je peux voir que les gens
qui nous a baisé bravo les attentats y
deviner si bien que chaque personne qui
est passé on a eu le temps de changer
tout ce que s'est passé à chaque fenêtre
revient fort heureux vous dit mais non
je te jure mais je suis la première
personne est bel et bien je vois bien
besoin d'aidé c'est incroyable ça a duré
moins de deux minutes soit est-ce qu on
peut accueillir quand même les autres
sosies
il aime pas qu pâques
c'est un traumatisme qui vient de se
passer et je me croyais qu'on était les
avengers des sosies bon c'est un peu
frustrant mais il reste deux personnes
je pense que sur les trucs audacieux ont
cette année là on comprend le temps
parce qu'alors la forme d'une minute
aucun bouton sûrement willis comprenant
apple c'est vrai moi je pense qu'on est
on a eu un excès de confiance ou trois
minutes on commence un peu allez on y va
et on envoie la sauce on envoie le char
à l'est les amis allez c'est parti
et l'on
c'est pas demain non pardon bienvenue
jeanne on est on est en train de faire
de s'entraîner pour notre atelier
vraiment rassurent tout on n'est pas sur
un niveau
sans dsk a chassé de la cie non j'ai
regardé les vidéos de ce quiz et avril
je me suis dit bon patrice a déjà été
fait il bon bah
vous trop si c'est parti bah moi je
pense je vais réussir ici celle enfin on
n'en doute pas une seconde que tout le
monde se doute que s'il ya bien un mec
qui a un bon niveau d'activités
manuelles dans cette pièce ouais on a
des couteaux dans la cuisine way a du
bon les appareils dans les allées reims
aînés ont le droit mais
j'avoue que là je vais d autres il
n'a jamais fait la discute dans mes
frais rod a déjà trois branches c'est
normal ça
mais on a vu sur mac il y en a que deux
sur le solde est en toi tu fais du
désert su quoi pour rien lauren stopper
est ce que tu peux me refaire
ok rapidement rapidement
un
arbre en fait en moins concrètement toi
il est un peu de ces mastodontes tonga
cussenot l'opa d'agde a perdu une minute
trente nam est déjà incroyable
l'organe est là elle a plein de plantes
chez elle elle connaît tous [ __ ] de
souvient d'aloe vera qu'on a nos bureaux
oui elle est dead arrosée pendant g on
acheter quand à bouger quoi du bureau
le coup de pression est lancée il faut
que vous sachiez menton voilà la [ __ ] à
qui veut que je ramène un truc pour
sécher les mains
moi je te plaît m'a dit je te remets ça
aucun tir sa
femme sceptique c'est trop
il dégage
dégage la
juste au bild la rose
[Musique]
non vraiment
non non c'est ma passion de pousser non
algériens font les défauts n'est pas
cadrée fait évidemment pas un canard
mais c'est une sacrée de faire je crois
que plus on voulait trouver une perche
il fait des jeux de mots assez gros
soucis
à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quel moment agréable un problème avec un
monsieur qui était retourné genre et qui
permettront une ba ba ouais ouais ouais
c'est à quel moment ça ils étaient déjà
tous cas les ce sera fort fort fort nous
ne t'a pas vu
[Applaudissements]
la perche du coup la mer j'avoue j'ai de
tout et pas dur mobile trop chaud
là je me suis dit basiques tels silos
mettre le micro un peu plus farah et
tout c'est moi je connais pas
c'est vrai lauren tu la regardes et tu
étais pas dit que c'était pas lorraine
je n'ai pas regardé comme je la regarde
maman je regardais genre toi j'ai vu le
même hall vip j'ai vu les cheveux d'ange
en effet faut le dire je suis membre
jusqu'à - l a pas vu quoi non mais c'est
alors qu'on avait commencé la journée en
disant oui l'objectif ultime c'est ça on
n'a fait que faire l'objet donc pour
cette fois on s'est dit on va pas
refaire comme la vôtre partout cette
fois ou trois minutes l'abonné va être
appelé parce qu'il a un problème
technique comme nous quand on sort et
quand il va revenir ce sera directement
de trois sosies en place ça si ça passe
c'est genre ok rien que le prochain
valentine tu peux faire venir à bout des
seins à personne c'est parti
la fin de journée dans les salles imax
tout roule secours enchanté ouais écoute
nous on est rodé on fait de la poterie
depuis ce matin donc nous allons aussi
des professionnels
personnes alors est ce que valentine je
peux nous montrer le dernier objet de
cette journée
let's go somers et le boss final et
qu'en fait je sais même pas dit je suis
moi même pas par où commencer enfin elle
a bien compris ah ouais
le mes chroniques et yappa celui-ci
propose pose à tous d'aller chercher son
micro il est temps d en bas en bas en
bas en bar en bas tu vas pouvoir
jeux la cuisine les soucis
légalement ces composés de sacs de sable
gris perfide et pertinents
ok c'est bon tout est réglé
[Musique]
allez fils de [ __ ]
[Rires]
alors désolé de mauvaise qualité mais
ça et c'est quoi ton cheminement de
pensée alors j'ai regardé les uns il
dispute pas beaucoup tué après j'ai vu
lucas je me suis
le vrai but c'était vraiment de swap
avec des sosies sauf que pour comme tel
dernier on s'est dit comme des merdes et
on s'est dit on de logrono on s'est dit
on soit tous ensemble à ce qu'il fallait
en soi pecqueux un way en armant ont
soif et chacun notre tour ben
franchement genre tendance au km 100 %
jugent inadaptée tu vois ces patients
est ce que tu te rends compte mais kz2
tout cela pour la valeur d'autant que tu
as vécu cette rencontre ouverte et vidéo
bon ben maintenant je veux être là
pendant 10 secondes
max du coup ça c'était juste un prétexte
mais au final on décide quand même de
définir un gagnant max je suis désolé tu
n'as pas gagné
c'est pas grave on peut pas griller des
sosies en une seconde et gagner
généralement c'est l'un ou l'autre moi
je pense que c'est lauren qui correspond
au thème est celui de sa vidéo
incroyable mais il est couché quoi tiens
on pense
c'est godzilla
max c'était le dernier et j'ai adoré ta
réaction tu m'as réglementaire
s'applaudir une d'un apport des coûts
de plus
les dames c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'ai passé un moment merveilleux je vous
dis la vérité je suis choqué de fou que
c'est autant marcher c'est trop drôle
sur le fond faisant des trucs presque
trop on veut tester les limites je suis
choqué après c'est normal c'est ce
mélange de impressionné par le tournage
impressionné aussi peut-être de nous
voir en vrai tu vois je pense qu'il a
plu par regarder énormément de vidéos
depuis un bon moment mais en vrai de
vrai il ya quand même un truc c'est que
des fois il voyait vraiment pas ce m
soit pour toi soit à saint-aignan des
fois il voyait vraiment pas quoi moi
j'aimerais bien le vivre de l'autre côté
là lorsque vous ce que ça fait qu'est-ce
qui disjoncte exactement en tout cas
merci évidemment à lucas gwendal et
lucile nos sosie ils ont été très bon en
vrai de vrai ce qu'il fait parce que le
monde ne vivront pas de la vidéo ils
font pas tout ça c'est un exercice qui
est compliqué c'est impressionnant merci
encore nous avait régalés à la fin de
cette vidéo c'est la fin de ces huit
heures de tournage je suis heureux
d'avoir vécu ça avec vous c'était genre
où je regarderai un souvenir de fou bref
faites un petit bisou à m'excuser cela
rassure
[Musique]